welcome to the second talk today the
pleasure for us within the next speaker
yang Liu he is currently a doctoral
candidate at Universidad politécnica de
Madrid and his research interests are in
the areas of natural language processing
machine running with special interests
on distribute tourism patient learning
and it's applications and neural
language processes tasks he will give us
your talk for increasing the trading
prediction with many aggregated human
texting message thank you very much and
a big applause for gangly good morning
everyone and a little low is because it
Elise is my first presentation in the
further professional audience so I have
some mistake please forgive me okay
now I begin in my participation my title
is increased training protection by
mining a curriculum a text message the
duration the NLP and another area is the
condiment
investment because these are all ways to
from the tech test to extract some
information to insider finance and a
give you some does business a decision
to the in list how to use us investors
or stock how to use the how to avoid the
Thunderer finance risk so and catchy
student and from China and my name is
Jung Yeo now my major is a business
Tanja's from the universitat politècnica
de modeling I have my presentation is
the four paths one is a our chart of
structure to it's a settlement analyze
three is the model collection and a
prediction for it sir
for is their conclusion and the fixture
work okay the beginning of foster part
oh I read read a match mother paper
relation to his area so I wrote and the
one method due to pure Dalek methodology
to the poles and Israel predicted
predicted the soccer ball movement and
is based on the text mining social media
and financial news so I can I can v2 is
the three ways to increase job by even
stage ok the user worker is a very
effective to the extractor the social
media and financial news this research
is the very spec further market I also -
in which certain market of Indochina and
the spin and the USA this is my book
flow you can see and the four pass the
corpus is a from the three-part social
media a financial news and stock market
then I use the prophesizing second one
slips other one is the model crucial use
iron and the CNN is of focus on the
table only model production mister use a
model prediction and the model you will
involution okay before I extend the
little process next one is in the
processing as ours to the high a Jeff
extractor to use higher height highlight
because a I don't I related the context
because there were components so chapter
I did extract
the news highlight because as a worry
effector in the focus on everyday and
the fake to the store walk
what and open the water lactic addiction
division re next one I just the user the
two ways to read relation pristine
recall and the key folder okay second
one is the settlement analyze data
resource this is a totally data from the
CNN as just the to the capture all night
in the CNN and stock page from the
standard power 500 this is from the
Yahoo Finance the average taraji Israel
from the May 2006 2 to 5 Lari 2007 17 oh
this is a focus on the industry it the
IT company but now just our focus on the
one company name in the fixture I'll
focus on the war match and Boeing
because it's a different industry the
wettable through a wearable page news
title news title and the cover cost
reporting and socket indicate oh this is
I show you the financials as I capture
online in the thunder later and a title
is the from the airy that because butter
you should I show you for example 26 I
have the hi loose
so just like you later the list is stay
okay and so on because it is the data
have the 5,000th
category so it's a much more secure
selection
you know the signature selection is in
the text mining very important so I can
choice the some doorways to
change Italy text - director or longer
have the one in the module information
second 180
tf-idf you know that tf-idf is a very
popular in the text mining three is PCA
for is a cost extra P trouble already
the similar term Kiev IDF butter now
some person is a user tf-idf
okay information Gong Li di OTA LGA and
many money person user little ways to
training the some de commerce text water
extending or depending is from the 2013
is a hot or Islam is this macaroni
including two of us Israel one is a walk
to water
another one is the fastest but today
today I just used work director to
training my data model encryption oh
this is a waste which shoulder how to
use the work director input is a one
document Israel simulator for example
every data title to inside a little
water to actor out out approach is the
shoulder some the distance and the is
the emotional in the list space in the
hall in the calculator the list of words
in the list space that is tense and
history for example Spain BGM leather
and Italian is the the is the vector
where we similar so I can never show you
model in inclusion for example what if
you ever use the tool model continue
back over Wars for example I and the dog
I add a dog is long can be a
like for example I like dog is the too
long to export or wearable continue
escape escape gram in for example like
is the way available to for example I
like you see like the talk so can be
export that I like a dog is long is that
to model it line is the continue bag of
words and otherwise skip gram one
example is an example from the one table
very famous in this area for example
this type is the example it told us show
me the highlight is the poached heel
like the two words for example file
disappointment counselor worried or no
okay it's the someone summary to divide
that by water to actor and I computer
put the least that low in emotional that
intruder is is there space can be to
coverage thus there's some similar the
world that is tense and I can analogize
the worst semantic in the is space now I
show you the the by decor test quoted
from the is the software well from the
French
Oh
you
okay here
you can you can I can show me the wonder
table is in the man in the world is the
dispute in the lift space is it already
many the emotional oh this the tater is
a piece a monitor before I show you the
Google News is a Islam is these texts of
chapter totally culture aligned in the
from the CLN so you can change you can
see the thunder was for example I find a
good is the positive words
for example here is Israel one
non-google he the same the worried term
no longer the distance is a facebook
here such good
and for example I shoulder that cell
collector the walls is for example
video-making is their feminine very
similar details in the least space
because it is data
I told to related some the Roy's because
of for example the Lois is it some the
two or do or watch is that noise day was
so you can adjust a shoulder some a
rotator you know okay continue
you
with a moment story
you
okay the then I first first step I
calculated the sum the distance in the
one space you apply the work director so
then add two cusps fire from the data
you apply the logical regression this is
a table tinder is the represent the
protein course presented early
literature some square to the led to net
kill the world so the circle first step
identity related a circle because
someday before I show you what's under
Louis dater so ideal eight elisa loi
stator so if the hole is the
representative noise later okay they'll
cough cough strictly a sediment i've
just a focus on the construction that
subtext to first footstep of finest and
elective war by the o2 actor because of
the i javelin see this underworld exam
before I show you the some the fire
disappointment is a worry easier to find
out user space Segawa is a design the
linear regression to fine to cut a
collapse fire three class okay
design the structure due to the club
very much okay continue is the happy is
a robbery oh one person in the China is
a NBA NBA player player is a Yamin okay
is a I chapter to present at Castle one
positive is a labourer in the class zero
okay either he is the word rich quiet
that's let you and let you class let's
keep the one okay is the processing
image model
inputs use title figure selection
because I just rejoice work order to
access other puts picture cause of
lecture 1 the 0 and the 1 of a summary
these process is the folks on the
Thunder salute salute the solve the
Thunder place under work because it is
pleasure on what is total is Roy's
second OVA is to worry collective
classifiers under worse in the postulate
literature and left y3 Israel I can put
a improve Israel accurate prediction
accuracy is a very better and to reduce
some des rois in the list space ok model
correction and a prediction Oh is my I
designed er one model in the tip alone
Ling
ok user shoulder input layer is a
feature vector the three parts inside a
count of illusion
they are poly layer and the hidden layer
output is the MUX is the result of the
stock up and the data input input layer
is the feature class in the inside
asunder like that q10 one hidden area is
some department
so use the tensor flow a player is the
the result of the sound of spoken
indicate up or down okay three cards
feature class is before I show you use
the work to actor two outputs under
three class inside is model so be easier
can be improved prediction accuracy
second layer the tournament of robot
wake
instead Maria is just er collusion the
three layer below layers the put in
including the pudding layer conclusive
collusion layer and create a layer so
the layer the result of the stock just
to predict that a Lister stock up or
down Oh convolution and the signature
work because the floral I think the
accuracy that gives the result always
beyond emotion and when the key was very
important because of the histor area is
where we expect special so I always to
elate some their noise data is very
difficult
then even models speak in code the
inside edges preferential is a worry
difficult because I always focus on
every day to reduce before I showed one
data I don't know have a Kevlar have the
27 and February but not to have the 26th
February so it's a very noise you
affected the state rotator and I always
do a focus on huge the some rotator
because a is a news for exact for
example in the Twitter in a so you know
Weber or the idiot is a China torture
and financial news because I use the
financial use I can connector the
tungsten Muto Bloomberg or CNN or BBC
okay fixed should walk I improved our
little prediction system because as a
user other developing Gong area unique
knowledge
okay second no one Iowa priorities model
the other area for example I can avoid
the financial risk the example the
Thunder pattern and contact okay mmm
sense for attention because the histor
diesel research is the my paper and
andrea reading his paper so i don't show
the some the cold I'm sorry do some do
have some any question any question
please
I got two questions the first one is
when will the material that you just
show that will be available online to
the consult see again all the things
that you show us today when they will be
uploaded online so I can download it and
see it well
when yeah when this year okay
and the only one what kind of pulling
did you use in your moving layers oh
this is a chapter into the model yeah I
know his model yeah yeah oh this is the
my designer layer so I can try the some
the this the Parliament I just to
physical this is it in my image that is
the pattern I I to try the from the
nintendon't flow by radicular accuracy
and to compare the Aries algorithm for
example Allen and the Ceylon so a
compare other I don't know I don't want
to tell you the accuracy because at
least is of my paper so I don't know pop
I don't know I don't know publish in my
paper so I don't show you the whole
story okay
questions by Sam's one thank you for the
great presentation first of all about
what to pick
did you use the pre train model or you
train your own model because oh we need
to model one either like what trick so
don't use director okay please do not oh
oh oh I use it a quartet to the college
someday these tents now you are because
two classifiers as is that Oh that team
some though let you put give the word to
use it a logical decoration to
classifier but the model is big friend
or like you train the role model because
you can use like free trim or no do
model chapter use up some dirt
use a live model to correlate that
attends the outputs on the vector nan
use the floor logical decoration to use
the register location to the calcloud
fighter three car and circuit before I
show you I told I told you it or Thunder
let u 1 0 and L 1 is 3 cups okay okay
thanks more questions
and my any questions in questions I have
one which languages are supported by now
with vector toward cortex which
elaborates which languages Chinese and
English
these two what only these two English
aunty is a chapter to compare this model
perform performance but a further step
adjuster use the English the two
connected from the English title the
channel focus on the title and the
second segment step I focus on the
Chinese because that I have the from the
rotator from the we were you know we
were is a Chinese or creature so I use
this model to training some the Chinese
Chinese data so to two dollars you and I
think the third name step use the stead
Spanish because I know the Spanish so
okay you guys have some question one
you know if you know some different into
the Spanish head to the English and
Chinese a resource yeah you had okay
I showed a shoulder and went on it then
the individual vector model you apply
you don't apply a stop words
why did you don't apply the Dexter words
did you have the difference it into this
these two I don't understand PC they
can't exchange
okay I thought stop words the apply stop
watching the work vector error model
stop words so also on yeah oh wait I
show you the stones but but have there
is not one the picture because a
dictionary of the thumb the positive and
negative actually is not have that you
can turn the alive okay but they are
different in the model when you apply
the stud words or no source for example
to to and some the other crease nach
Kevlar resolved some the exact effective
the words for example the protein was
faced with a moment our shoes
[Music]
kind of worse there is typical tourist
parties you can show me later okay yeah
I should I keep customer yeah in the
horse okay thank you thank you sorry you
got you back
hi
you said that you're also using a
concurring neural network I guess for
the stock price analysis not for the
sentiment part but how are you combining
both then oh so now I trained in this
data is a sum the pokey to present data
up label a literature is a stable post
let him is the root senator tom is the
result but for example I caught in the
everyday have the Sunda use title to
combine the every day the stock tick
indicates to predict but I don't know I
don't show I don't show you the sounder
store indicate sorry okay
any one more questions no then if big
applause and out
[Applause]